a fast growing economy and easy access
to good food has led to fast-growing
waist lines in China over the past two
decades data from the Chinese Center for
Disease Control and Prevention show
about ten percent of over a teens were
classified as obese in 2010 and that
number is increasing rapidly or mph a
panic on the mail having guard that'll
make you there for that our obesity
ratio is not as high as Europe for the
u.s. we have a far larger population
base and our rate of increase is very
fast we've record an annual increase of
four percent for the over white
population and nine percent for the
clinically obese population the increase
rate is quite high particularly among
the male population China spent about
330 million dollars on health projects
last year trying to get the nation
moving launchings concerns about his
long-term health led him to join this
weight-loss program in Beijing yeah what
some young Apollo your size you will
learn some friends of mine are getting
cerebral thrombosis and hemorrhages when
they're only in their mid-30s it made me
realize it's quite easy for overweight
guys like us to get these diseases
that's why I'm here to reduce my weight
Oh full on living conditions are better
people are eating better than before
however they are not selective enough
about eating food they stuff all kinds
of delicious food into their mouths and
have become fond of eating this has
tremendously increased the burden on our
bodies rates of obesity related diseases
such as diabetes are soaring in China
putting a strain on the health system
but government policy and public health
campaigns can change eating habits
Denmark introduced strict trans fat
regulations and is reported South
Korea's public education program has
managed to increase the intake of fruit
and vegetables Ross Lynch in Bloomberg
Hong Kong